peter what's up my man my wife and i are
at a crossroads with our church
and we're trying to decide as to whether
we should stay
and uh but we're not in agreement on it
oh okay so what's going on with your
church so this is a church i've been to
since i was a
young boy i'm an adult now with kids
okay and
um we had a pastor change about four
years ago
and there have been some
disagreements on the way
things should work there's been little
hurts there's been a little offenses
um and it's like you're talking about
you're talking pretty vague
like little hurts little fences pointed
at your wife at the church community
what
do you what who's hurt and what well
so our pastor came in and is
is i don't know how it says the initial
offense was with my wife she was
she had lost a close family member and
uh no one from the church leadership
really reached out to her did anything
like that
okay and so that was a deep seed hurt
there's some very progressive attitudes
yeah
from our our leadership regarding um
race and taking offenses at uh
at different decorations um
here they've brought into the church
that i've disagreed with okay
and again it's not all bad it just seems
like it's little cuts here and there
that keep building and
and my wife has had enough and i would
like to
stay and work through it and i know i'm
not a grasses greener kind of guy so i
understand that
nowhere is going to be perfect but it's
caused quite a bit of stress in our
relationship in the last year or so
and we're trying to figure out how to
work through it together gotcha
so this is less about when do you leave
a church
and more about how do you and your wife
come together to make decisions for the
both of you right
yeah i guess i mean it's all been
centered around the church so
yeah yeah that's i mean that's the easy
neon sign to point at
um so what what is it
that you want to stick around for
well i still have family there um
uh again the there's going to be a
stress in leaving that church and
finding another church and
getting and you know establishing
relationships that way
why does she want to leave she just
tired she's tired of listening to you
is she tired of every week it's another
thing that you're upset about
and she's like let's just go or is she
saying if i keep going to this place
i'm going to continue to be
uncomfortable
uh yes some of that um
i i seem to have a beef more often than
not with something that's happened or
something that's been said most of her
friends
are gone at church now a lot of people
have left our church
since the new pastor has come um
so let me ask you this what is that what
does winning look like here
or let me ask you this let me back it up
before that
you talk about there's new attitudes on
progressive thought there's new
attitudes on race there's new attitudes
on
hey we're gonna do things differently
are you interested in sitting down and
learning new things tell me about why
this is
or are you more interested in this is
the way this is supposed to be
y'all are not doing it the way it's
supposed to be done and i'm going to
be here and i'm going to engage with
this community
until we get it back to the way it's
supposed to be what are your two
that's kind of a binary choice which one
are where are you
well i've certainly had to swallow my
own pride and
willingness
say that again you've swallowed your own
pride in what
yeah i lost you man
are you still there yeah there we go so
you had to swallow your own pride in
yeah i've had to learn new things um
and i've had to accept that but at the
same time
i think there are certain foundational
things i'm not willing to move on
and i've resisted that spoke to my
pastor
about it so per se
um so yeah i guess i'm kind of a little
bit of both
okay sounds like you
i mean there's one or two choices man it
sounds like your wife is tired of
either her husband hurting tired of her
husband's
whining about it or tired of
um not being in any sort of agreement
and so she's like man let's just go
somewhere else
and this is a place that you'll be
pretty well summed up okay
and you've got deep-seated roots here
you love this place you love what it's
been about more importantly you love
what it has meant
to you meant past tense
and now it is you're looking to
what the future is going to look like
and you don't know what that's going to
look like
and here's here's what i'm gonna tell
you man this ends up
at some point with you leaving or are
you running a minister out of town
and nobody feels good on the back end of
that either
right and those are my only two choices
i mean what's the third choice
give me the way we're going give me what
a win is gonna look like for you
that one day your your pastor's gonna
call you in and be like you know what
man
you're right i'm wrong let's go back to
the way it was
i'm going to do a couple of sermons on
how to how to go back you know i mean
like what what do you think
the wind looks like
well for the sake of sounding arrogant
i'm hopeful my wife can
address some of her hurts and grow past
it
and form just
but
say it one more time
yeah i lost you man um
so here's the thing um
when you find yourself in a place where
a community is moving
one direction or the other from you and
you have learned some new things but
there's also a lines that you're not
going to cross
whatever that may be right let me i'm
trying to think of one that's non
it's not a third rail um thinking about
like
learning math my my son i started
teaching him the
the way i learned math which evidently
isn't cool anymore
and it's not the right way to teach a
kid how to do math my son is so much
better at math than i was
and my wife attributes that to new
teaching models and math
and at first i was like oh they're just
messing with these kids these days
back in the old days i had to memorize
the facts and whatever and my wife's
like how'd that work out for you and i
was like well played
and so i sat down and had my son teach
me a few new things
and i thought man that's really good and
i did think man there's just some stuff
you got to memorize
right you just got to memorize that 9
times 9 is 81 right you just got to
memorize some stuff
but at the end of the day i'm not
teaching math i'm not absorbed in it i'm
i'm stepping out of that conversation
i'm not going to engage with it anymore
i trust my teachers that are
the teachers are teaching my son and
then they're moving on with it right
and so at some point you got to say hey
this community's moved on to a different
place right wrong or indifferent i'm
going to mourn it and grieve it and then
i'm going to
create a new community wishing your wife
would change the way she feels change i
don't think it has to do with
getting over her issues man i think it
has to do with
she's tired of listening to you she's
tired of every sunday
the church is supposed to be a place
where we go all say hey we're all broken
we're all screwed up and we all look at
each other and go oh man me too
you two and everybody exhales
and everybody locks arms and then we go
serve the least of these
we feed the homeless we take care of the
poor
and then we go about our week and then
we circle back and
when church turns into fights and
yelling
and let's let's go to war against
everyone else
man it's just it's not what it was
designed to be
and so my guess is your wife's done with
that part of it
and man i'm gonna tell you you're
you can go to war with them man try to
get the guy fired
try to bring your church back to its
roots and
make some changes and you can do that
and if you find
peace in that then so be it
my thought on when it's time to leave a
church is this
when they're no longer upholding their
mission to care for widows and orphans
when they spend more money on the church
show on the lasers and the smoke than
they
are on actually serving others when
their identity becomes one of a fighting
culture other people other churches
fighting takes precedence over cups of
water feeding orphans taking care of the
least of these
that's when me and my family that's when
we're out right
that's when we're out when church
becomes a show when it becomes a
performance
um that's when we're gonna step away it
also is a place where we hold each other
accountable right we have hard
conversations
but if we wait until these last few
moments to do that if we wait until
these third rail political
man it's already lost it so i don't know
if that answers your question brother
i'm sorry i lost you there but
um it sounds to me like y'all are done
and i'd love to sit have you sit down
with your wife and say i think i want to
go find another place
where would you like to go and then just
go visit some other places man try it
and see what that'll look like for you